un mapping au collège saint-augustin de
saint-germain-en-laye un aboutissement
pour cette trentaine d'élèves de
troisième réalisateur en herbe le temps
d'une année ils ont planché sur ce court
métrage pendant quatre mois ça a été du
travail d'une petite scène une petite
cette nécessité effectivement des heures
et des heures de montage on est très
fiers de cette vidéo on est content de
l'avoir fait on est content or passer
toutes ces heures dessus ça fait plus de
quatre mois qu'on travaille sur ce
projet et là c'est vraiment moi c'est à
la grande soirée on est tous pressés de
voir le résultat aucun élève n'a pu voir
le court métrage avant sa projection ils
ont découvert le rendu le jour j parents
d'élèves corps enseignant et publics
extérieurs ont pu admirer avec fierté le
résultat sur la façade du collège on a
tous tourné presque le dernier jour donc
on n'avait que trois heures pour ton et
la majorité des scènes on la fait tous
dans la bonne humeur et on s'attendait
vraiment pas à ce que sa vente aussi
aussi bien sincèrement c'est la première
fois qu'on voyait tout a semblé qu'on
allait pas beaucoup de temps donc
l'intervenant a fini chez lui à dire
vrai je ne savais pas trop à quoi
m'attendre réellement donc non j'ai
trouvé que c'était un travail de belles
qualités après je savais ce qu'ils
avaient dessiné exactement mais non j'ai
trouvé que c'était vraiment plutôt bien
réussi
pour ce projet les élèves ont été
initiés par un intervenant au papier
découpé à la technique image par image
une aventure collective où chacun a
apporté sa pierre à l'édifice résultat
notre petit monde un court métrage de
cinq minutes qui traite de la
civilisation il y avait quelque part une
génèse en fait à depuis le début de la
création du monde avec
les dinosaures ensuite les animaux et
puis l'homme qui arrive qui crée un
habitat qui détruit du coup pour pouvoir
étendre en fait son habitat le mapping a
été réalisée le 24 mai le court métrage
est disponible en ligne
[Musique]